Новини дня «Heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Вітаю вас у десятихвилинному випуску новин!
Німецькі футболістки змагаються за
титул чемпіона Європи.
Руді, які є ще новини спорту на сьогодні?
Поміж іншого перший раунд Кубку Німеччини
з футболу, більше про це згодом.
Сьогоднішні теми випуску:
Нова зброя для російського флоту:
президент Путін оголосив про додаткове озброєння.
Без повернення до атомної енергетики:
лідерка партії Зелених Рікарда Ланґ
у інтерв'ю ZDF розповідає про
технології підвищеного ризику.
Потік медалей на воді: дві золоті медалі Німеччини
наприкінці Чемпіонату світу
з веслування на байдарках і каное в Ауґсбурзі.
Президент Путін назвав США та НАТО
найбільшими загрозами для Росії.
Сьогодні він представив нову воєнну доктрину
для Військово-морського флоту (ВМФ).
У документі є твердження, що США хочуть
домінувати у Світовому океані.
Тому Росія хоче посилити свій флот у Чорному морі.
Фолькер Дучек розповість про
парад ВМФ у Санкт-Петербурзі
та про події війни в Україні.
158-й день війни з погляду Москви
є днем глянцевих картинок.
Паради в кількох містах до дня ВМФ.
Президент Путін у Санкт-Петербурзі.
Він оголошує про озброєння флоту
гіперзвуковими ракетами.
І ще важливіше: він запроваджує нову
Військово-морську доктрину,
що застерігає від порушення морських кордонів Росії.
Це послання перш за все для США
та їхніх НАТО-союзників.
Ми забезпечимо захист наших кордонів
усіма можливими засобами.
Тут важливими також є здібності ВМФ.
Він здатен оперативно відреагувати на дії кожного,
хто вирішить зазіхнути на наш суверенітет і свободу.
Донбас на 158-й день війни, наступ росіян триває.
Принаймні про це свідчать світлини від Міноборони.
Загроза мирному населенню зростає.
Це бачить і влада у Києві.
Президент Зеленський закликає мешканців Донбасу
покинути домівки.
Сотні тисяч людей, десятки тисяч дітей
відмовляються це робити.
Але це справді необхідно.
І що швидше вони це зроблять, то менше людей
на Донеччині будуть вбиті російською армією.
Сьогодні було здійснено атаку безпілотників
на штаб російського Чорноморського
флоту в Севастополі.
За декілька годин до виступу Путіна.
Офіційні представники звинувачують Україну.
Їхній флот заперечує атаку.
У будь-якому разі парад тут скасували.
Зважаючи на війну в Україні,
Німеччина намагається позбутися залежності
від російського газу.
Дедалі гучніша вимога: залишити АЕС
підключеними до мережі довше.
Партія Зелених, що виникла з антиядерного руху,
за певних обставин підтримала б
тимчасове продовження експлуатації,
але не більше.
Саме тому виникла суперечка
із коаліційним партнером FDP.
Сьогодні в інтерв’ю ZDF співлідерка Зелених
Рікарда Ланґ
розповідала про це. Томас Райхарт.
На інтерв'ю із лідеркою партії Зелених
за столом сидить ще один непомітний гість.
Крістіан Лінднер знову пояснив,
що в крайньому разі атомні електростанції повинні
залишатися підключеними до мережі до 2024 року.
Це призвело до відкритого конфлікту
у «світлофорній» коаліції.
Коли Ви припините чинити опір
продовженню експлуатації?
Прагнення Крістіана Лінднера не що інше, як
прагнення повернення до атомної енергетики.
Цього не має статися в жодному разі.
Ланґ звинувачує Лінднера у «несерйозній дискусії»
та стверджує, що
атомна енергетика навряд чи допоможе замінити
нестачу російського газу.
Річ у тім, що газові електростанції в Німеччині
дуже малою мірою використовуються для
виробництва електроенергії.
І вони лише незначною мірою можуть бути замінені
атомною енергією.
Ми маємо проблему з теплом, а не з електроенергією.
Єдине обмеження для їхнього спротиву
щодо експлуатації АЕС:
якщо нове стрес-тестування покаже
труднощі з електроенергією.
Через високі витрати на електроенергію Ланґ закликає
до подальших субсидій для малозабезпечених.
Наприклад, за рахунок податку на надприбуток
енергетичних компаній,
які зараз отримують значно вищі прибутки.
Лінднер, який сьогодні дає інтерв'ю,
знову протестує.
Ми повинні зробити усе для того, щоб захисти людей
від інфляції та подолати її причини.
Наша ціль є, отже, однаковою.
На шляху до цієї цілі реакції можуть відрізнятися.
Ланґ, наприклад, апелює до реакції Лінднера:
у розпал кризи він має відмовитися
від свого опору призупиненню
боргового гальма на довший період.
Думаю, кожен має бути готовим зробити неможливе.
Цього я очікую і від коаліційного партнера.
Найпізніше до кінця літа вони
мають вирішити суперечку.
Коли уряд знову сидітиме за одним столом.
Повне інтерв'ю із співлідеркою партії Зелених
можна переглянути одразу
після закінчення цього випуску
або в будь-який час у нашій медіатеці.
Спочатку наземний персонал заблокував
роботу Lufthansa страйком,
а тепер пілоти також готуються до страйкової боротьби.
Під час попереднього голосування
профспілки «Cockpit»
значна більшість пілотів проголосувала за страйк,
якщо Lufthansa не зробить кращої пропозиції.
Вони вимагають підвищення зарплати на 5,5%
та компенсацію інфляції.
Ці дії викликали жах.
Нещодавно було знищено кілька меморіальних дерев
жертвам нацистського концтабору Бухенвальд.
Прем'єр-міністр Тюрингії Рамелов оголосив,
що він скасує свою відпустку
та буде присутнім сьогодні на заході
вшанування пам'яті єврейських дітей,
які були депортовані з Бухенвальду до Освенцима.
На їхню честь було закладено більше каменів.
Репортаж від Флоріана Корчіка.
Марш пам'яті супроводжують музиканти.
Цією дорогою колись нацисти вивезли 2000 дітей
з Бухенвальду до табору смерті Освенцим.
Станом на сьогодні 111 пам'ятних каменів
вшановують їхню пам'ять.
Убиті були людьми.
Їхнє життя було зруйновано.
Дуже важливо вшанувати їхнє життя
та розмістити їхні імена на цій старій доріжці.
Неподалік колишнього концтабору
протягом останніх тижнів
невідомі неодноразово вирубували
та нищили меморіальні дерева.
Вони були висаджені в пам'ять про дітей,
вбитих у Бухенвальді, та інших в'язнів.
Це викликало обурення всієї країни.
Коли хтось вирубує дерева,
присвячені дітям і молоді Бухенвальду,
то це цілеспрямована атака вшанування пам’яті,
культури пам'яті,
це має політичні мотиви.
На меморіалі також часто зустрічаються
правоекстремістські графіті та посили ненависті.
І не лише там.
Ми бачимо, що частота таких інцидентів
в останні роки та на тлі
коронавірусної пандемії зросла.
Інцидент належить до форми антисемітизму,
яка применшує значення
масових злочинів нацистів.
Тому так важливо боротися
із антисемітизмом у всіх його проявах.
За допомогою просвіти, освіти та дій.
Щоб пам'ятати і не забувати.
Китайська велика транспортна ракета
впала над Південно-Східною Азією.
NASA це гостро розкритикувало:
маневр був неконтрольованим
і Пекін не поділився жодною інформацією
щодо цього процесу.
Більшість частин ракети згоріли
під час входження в атмосферу Землі.
Але, очевидно, деякі уламки також
впали в море біля Філіппін.
Рік тому Китай зазнав міжнародної критики
через схожий ризикований маневр.
А тепер, як і обіцяли, поговоримо з Руді
про Кубок Німеччини з футболу.
Це не було сюрпризом, але «Фрайбурґ», лише
доклавши зусиль, дійшов до другого раунду Кубка.
ФК «Кайзерслаутерн», який піднявся
до другого дивізіону,
виграв лише після додаткового часу з рахунком 2:1.
Перед майже 40 тисячами глядачів на Бетценберзі
учасник Ліги Європи «Фрайбурґ» мав пройти
складне кубкове випробування.
На 111-й хвилині порятунком для команди Бундесліги
став гол Ріцу Доана.
Інші результати сьогоднішньої гри Кубку:
«Кайзерслаутерн» програв «Фрайбурґу» з рахунком 2:1
після додаткового часу.
«Зандгаузен»перемагає «Реден»з рахунком 4:0.
«Шальке 04» впевнено веде, 5:0 проти «Бремер»
з четвертого дивізіону.
«Енґерс» програв з рахунком 1:7
«Армінії» з Білефельда.
«Боруссія» Менхенґладбах 9:1 проти «Оберахерн».
«Редінггаузен» програв «Гоффенгайм»
з рахунком 0:2 після додаткового часу.
«Шотт Майнц» 0:3 проти «Ганновер 96».
«Blau-Weiß Lohne» програв з рахунком 4:0
ФК «Ауґсбурґ».
На чемпіонаті світу в Ауґсбурзі
в останній день посипалися золоті медалі
для німецьких веслувальників на байдарках та каное.
В Ауґсбурзі народився
і в льодовому каналі Ауґсбурґа вперше виграв
золото чемпіонату світу.
Для Зідеріса Тасіадіса все завершилося.
Бронзовий призер Олімпіади в Токіо ризикував чимало
у фіналі класу човнів каное-одиночка
і був за це винагороджений.
На фініші 32-річний спортсмен проплив
на 1,18 секунди швидше,
ніж Олександр Слафковський із Словаччини.
Франц Антон здобув бронзу.
У фіналі каное-одиночок серед жінок Андреа Герцоґ
випереджає австралійку та головну фаворитку
Джессіку Фокс приблизно на секунду,
незважаючи на дотик до жердини.
Після 2019 року це друге золото ЧС у кар'єрі Герцоґ.
Олімпійська чемпіонка в перегонах на час
Аннемік ван Влейтен
виграла жіночий Тур де Франс.
Після того, як вчора 39-річна нідерландка
отримала жовту майку на королівському етапі,
сьогодні вона також здобула перемогу
на останньому відрізку довжиною 123,3 км.
Її землячка Демі Воллерінґ фінішувала другою
як на етапі, так і в загальному заліку.
Ліане Ліпперт посіла 14 місце,
найкращий результат серед німкень.
Чемпіон світу Макс Ферстаппен готується
захистити свій титул у «Формулі-1».
В Угорщині він піднявся з 10-го місця до перемоги,
це його восьма перемога в сезоні.
На другому місці Льюїс Гамільтон.
Він випередив свого напарника
в команді «Мерседес» Джорджа Рассела.
Себастьян Феттель приїхав десятим,
Мік Шумахер - чотирнадцятим.
Це всі новини спорту на сьогодні.
Дякую, Руді!
А зараз про погоду:
на сході та в центральній частині
хмарно з дощами та грозами.
Здебільшого сонячно, вдень на півдні місцями грози.
Максимальна температура від 18 до 31°С.
У наступні дні буде все більш сонячно та спекотно.
Мітрі Зірін з вами в ефірі о 21:45 у «Heute Journal».
А зараз ми продовжимо інтерв'ю
із співлідеркою Зелених Ланґ.
Гарного вечора!